you will start a little earlier so I
will control the time okay I will tell
you five minutes something like and we
have the arrow Python guys and they will
tell us about how they analyze the
flight safety data with Python so an
applause to them can you hear me well
okay as you know it's remove before
flight Andros giving this talk with my
friend Ando side a little bit of
self-promotion
we're both aerospace engineer Dean's
we're both passion for programming
especially for Python and the Python
community and as you know maybe not
we're members of Hydra Python which is a
group of other space engineers who
develop in Python tools okay so what is
the main objective for this talk
throughout the years of the university
we've been seen many figures and books
and stuff like that and once we felt
comfortable programming we wanted to
reproduce you those graphics with real
with real data so we found one database
on the internet and we start working
with it okay a little bit of disclaimer
we're not safety experts this has to be
very clear we're not experienced data
scientists so maybe the question that
comes to your mind is where are these
guys doing out here the answer is very
easy for us we're very enthusiastic
about Python and anything related with
it we're curious about anything related
also to the aerospace field so we
thought this could be great
for us and also for you to show you this
a little bit of this okay
before starting with the programming I'm
gonna show you a little bit of this
topic aviation safety would it solve
this about okay you can see flight
safety is has many stages as much as the
life of any aircraft the design that
involves the manufacture of the aircraft
the manufacturing certification may be
do you think that the most important for
safety agency I think you may think that
this operation but actually the whole
process must be must be studied for for
this topic it's not only operation that
is usually the topic the typical we're
gonna be focusing on the last one stage
the accident investigation because the
database we have is from this last stage
the organization that I studied this
topic there are many in the world one of
the most important is the Eco that we
can see here is part of the united
nation and we've taken some definitions
and some thought from these from this
organization we can see also the yachtie
which is where all the companies belong
to we can see American organizations
here in Europe we have the Euro control
that focuses on navigation focuses more
on the safety problem also every country
has their own Department from this topic
and here in Spain we have the Ministry
of mint
okay so once we decided to do this talk
we wonder where we can find the data for
for this topic and once we started
looking for it we realized that it was
not easy so we started thinking why why
is there is not so much that about this
and the reason is that well obviously is
a not an easy topic to talk about and
also there are some rules that say that
every every time that an accident occurs
the investigation must be done but the
publishing is not mandatory at least not
the detail the detail data so there are
some countries that provides that data
in there are others that we are happy
that the United States provided that and
those are the data that were using in
this talk well we're gonna be using
pandas that most of you know because
there has been a lot of talks with it
and if you are an expert of pandas I
hope you enjoy the safety part yeah
Society for the the main source for the
data is the National Transportation
Safety Board from the United States and
that's from where we get the this agency
is great not only the database anything
is public and the reports are fantastic
so let's start programming
this is computers it's my folder okay
okay so let's take a look at the
database without any filter the
important important information to
follow properly the top is that we can
see that any action has an event ID and
we can also see the different
information this database provides we
can see where the action occurs when or
how was the weather
so after this one of the data that was
very important for us was the the date
we realized that every it was a little
bit difficult to work with so we'll pass
it we can see we start with the problems
and any real database can have so this
database is supposed to start in 1982
but we can see here that there are six
accident before that data so okay so now
we start filtering the database we want
to focus on that the typical flight that
any of you or me can take so the the
first classification is about the type
of event we have two types basically one
is called an accident the one is called
an incident the for you to know the main
characteristic of an accident is what
you can read here when a person is
fatally or seriously injured or will the
aircraft sustained damage or a
structural failure or where the aircraft
is missing or is completely unacceptable
we're going to be focusing on the
accident or the incident so we can see
that we have more than 70,000 accidents
ok and now we've discard the incidents
and now we're gonna focus on as I said
before I want to show you some flight
that it's very common so the flight you
can classify in many different ways so
the way we've done to to get the flight
we want is whenever you focus in on a
classification that a specific agency
takes
we're gonna be taking those which are
called part 121 that are the big
aircraft with revenue commercial
aircraft and the non-us and commercial
aircraft so we do this in Python because
you different part part
okay one of the main methods we're using
here in this top is this one because the
problem is that the database is there
are many tables it's not one only table
so for in order to work with we need so
so after that we've here and we can see
that we have 1,500
okay so now that we have loaded the data
we are going to perform some analysis
and we are going to try some of the
questions you may be wondering the first
thing we are going to do is okay I
wanted to use base math I've been
wanting to do that for a long time and
now I had a lot of locations in a data
base so it was maybe a good idea to plot
where do accidents occur so what
information do we have about location in
our table events we can see we have the
name of the city the name of the state
the country also and we have some
information about latitude and longitude
which we cannot directly use because
someone had the idea of storing it as
hours minutes seconds plus
north-south-east-west so the first thing
we have to do is to parse it will have
some functions to that a very strong
regular expressions and the conversion
from hours to minutes and all of that
and after that process we can find that
there are more than 1000 event with no
location at all before but after the
filtering we will be working with 1500
events so almost no event have
information about location in terms of
latitude unknown heated as I really
wanted to use Bayes map and I couldn't
blow just 40 points or something like
that what I did is using Google code
okay here so as we had the information
about the city the state and also the
country why not sending that information
through the hello happy to Google and
then take the longitude the latitude and
longitude this is done in another
notebook
pull request to the main repository of
the conference and you can see that
there there's also a restriction on the
number of curious you can do everyday
and the cubes per second
so as we wanted to be trying I couldn't
do that alive and it would take some
time so I have the data loaded into into
another table this is the the table and
constructing to CERN to today Google a
peak hello code as you see a half
information city country state sometimes
about the state not always
and once I send it there and load it
here again there are only 44 events with
no information in terms of latitude so
now we have the information let's plot
and see what happens it takes a little
bit of time okay I don't know you see
something there but our main conclusion
here was okay they are not lying
the database is American okay
you can see there are some clusters that
there are places were no accidents oh
cool I mean let's focus on the states
and as you and I think you guess it's
related to the amount of traffic so we
got some information about airports from
another data source you have only data
sources in the repository also and let's
try to plot also the the airports
so in the upper part you can see every
airport in this database and in the
lower part we can see again the
accidents and we see as the accidents
concentrate around the airports or even
inside the airports we'll talk about
that a little bit more when we see the
causes of the accidents well not the
course is the a occurrences okay another
question is I'm taking my fly which is
when do accidents occur are there likely
to happen in in every phase of flight ok
just briefly the flight starts with the
plane part then you go and taxi to a
runway once you are in the wrong way you
take off you have a face of climb then
you reach the crease altitude this is
the most part of the flight at some
point you are near your destination so
the pilot put less power on the engines
just start descending and we'll have a
face of approach to the airport and
finally the landing normally the face of
the landing starts with the plane really
really close to the ground it's not what
people normally calls landing what
people normally what people calls normal
in London is approach + landing so take
this into account when we are plotting
things the database is really detailed
and it doesn't only make the distinction
in London approach there are different
phases in London for example so what we
are going to do is to group them all in
a general flight face London there and
this is what we are doing here ok
obviously it doesn't say London in the
database there are some codes so what we
are doing is to translate that codes
into something meaningful with the help
of the documentation about that database
which is also really good and will be
well documented well I'm saying it's
well documented right at the same time
I'm going to say that
were looking for this zero and there's
no information at all or at least we
were not able to find that so we are a
little bit curious about that okay so
which flight phase is safer or when do
accidents occur the most we can see
there are many accidents relating to
landing but if we add also the approach
phase there are even more so we would
say that's the most dangerous part
people is not normal is normally right
when they are afraid of landing and
taking off I mean they are not right but
is the more it's most likely to happen
there than in any other phase for the
flight we find also here takeoff people
normally grab the seat even take off and
we were surprised to find here taxi and
standing standing means the plane is
just stopped so something happens
suddenly there may be fire maybe another
plane passing by and touch your plane
this is considered an accident even if
no one results damn it or injured but it
can as we were showing firstly in the
definition if there's my or damaging the
plane as could be the case I invite you
to we didn't want to include pictures or
something like that even if it's just
for the plane but you can google for
that and sometimes one is like a car
crash but inside an airport and they
just touch with the wings in the wingtip
or something like that is not really
tangible but it is considered an
accident and it of course
so we've seen that there are many
accidents and I was telling you ok
let's have a look at the number of
injured people the number of fatalities
or also the damage to the airplane so we
construct this table based on the
information from some other tables in
the database and we can see by flight
face the damage to the aircraft which is
non
CEL destroyed meaner or unknown and the
number of injured people and faculties
for that fried face okay okay so maybe
it's better if we plot it we see it's
pretty straightforward to plot all the
data contained there with pandas that we
knew about we knew very little about
pandas when we started but I think we've
learned a lot and we found it difficult
at the beginning but then we discovered
this kind of tools and it's wonderful so
okay go in again to answer your
questions
we see a large amount of events do in
London and we see that normally the
aircraft experience is substantial
damage during landing it results
destroyed or substantially damaged it is
the same more or less doing take off
also the approach phase what we are
calling wrongly landing normally again
well however there are other flight
phases for example increase the aircraft
normally doesn't experience a lot of
damage
what happens here we'll see the number
of injured people and explain these
there but it could happen and we'll see
an example that you are sitting on your
seat in the airplane the seatbelt sign
is not turned on so we do decide to do
like this and suddenly something happens
turbulence or heart maneuver the Palio
dislike and you fly yeah okay
it happens and it results in injured
people normally it's not passengers but
flight attendants who are passing by the
the corridor the aisle of the plane
result injured a lot of times like this
so okay let's look at what happens to
people this
plot in the same order as before but
let's order by the number of fatalities
and we see take off is the worst one
if something happens there the airplane
is really close to around the manoeuvre
margin is low let's say that the system
would have to may made really fast so
it's critical and normally dangerous and
so the plane has a lot of fuel inside so
it end up with fire that causes a lot of
subtleties it happens more or less the
same we see the big blue bars for the
approach and climb face however let's
have a look at London injured people we
can find more injured people than
patentees so ok it's really well it's
not really probable it's most probable
that something happens during landing
but in case that happens there are more
chances that you survive which is good
to know also ok so let's have a look
also at the main accident occurrences we
decided to call it occurrences because
it's called occurrences in the table but
I'm going to explain you a little bit
more for this 7th IV we can see here
let's check what information we can find
in the occurrences table the very first
thing we can see is that there were two
aircraft involved we have aircraft key
one and attack aircraft key too so there
were two aircraft involved in this
accident and there are several
occurrences
again we identify its operands with a
code and I will explain you now a little
bit of these codes so we can see that
there's not like a one cause for each
seventh it's just some of things we will
produce about this case so we got more
information for it
we entered the ID in the events table so
we can see
in 1985 in Southaven the United States
and we also decided to look for the
report a brief report of them okay this
is the National Transportation Safety
Board webpage we can look for reports of
the accidents and we can have a look
there what happened there there was a
bigger plane above in 727 flying it was
starting the descent phase the seatbelt
sign was turned on okay and there were
some clouds so suddenly the pilot of the
of these big airplanes so another
aircraft it was a little aircraft okay
you're quicker than me so he saw that
and suddenly maneuver hardly this
resulted in some flight crew injured
with that and significant damage in the
little airplane they didn't collide but
you experienced significant damage
so okay again we are filtering the
occurrences there are the classification
is really detailed so we are grouping
them in bigger groups these bigger
groups are the ones you can see here
fire explosion force landing gear
collapse hard landing the difference
between force landing and hard landing
for example talk a little bit about it
for Sundanese that you need to land in
an unexpected place it's a not your
final destination and it's a place that
you are forced to choose because of my
or circumstances a hard landing is let's
say you lose a little bit the control of
the airplane it's not a lose of control
is like you go against that rain harder
than expected or that kind of things so
once we have these occurrences here we
again plot the number of accidents the
number of times it appears again it's
not that it's not the main course it's
just that this happen
and we find that encounters with bad
weather or unexpected weather for that
flight face are present in many many
accidents also collision with objects
even on ground this is what I was
talking about at the beginning we have
also collision in flight in flight
collision which is less common fire
explosions loss of engine power okay
many people think the worst thing that
can happen there in the air is that you
lose one engine maybe two of the engines
or maybe all if you have four okay
obviously it's not nice if that happens
but I have to say is not the worst thing
that it that kind can happen yeah
gliders fly without engines there's no
problem they fly you go smoothly down
you have time to react if you are - oh
you won't have much problems I mean it's
not nice it's not normal it's not
expected to happen but if it happens and
in many other flight phases even doing
the takeoff you have to certify your
plane to take off with just one plane
with that one engine from a certain
point of the taking off taking off okay
so we are discovering some interesting
data here another question you might be
asking is what impact that does
experience half I mean we are going to
evaluate experience in terms of eight of
the pilots and also in terms of flight
hours let's start with eight we have
this information available in this
database called flight crew we have
information about the age sex residents
country even the profession was over
there which is funny
okay not for general aviation general
aviation was contemplated also in this
database but we filtered and we've gone
only to commercial
okay as always we have some problems
with data with a lot of blank spaces and
all of that we filter and let's have a
look at the AIDS the mean AIDS of pilots
involved in accidents it's 44 years the
minimum 20 and okay maybe this box plot
can tell you more fifty percent of the
pilots are inside this box so this is
between 37 years old and 45 years old
so once we see this we would be tempted
to say okay so pilots between let's say
45 55 have more accidents than the
others okay no we are not experienced
data scientists but we know we have to
non-dimensionalize this data let's say
we have to take into account that the
majority of the pilots flying are in
that age how we did that okay
we went to this source of data is
compressed data inside a PDF and we
stuck to the values of the number of
licenses for pilots last year in 2015 so
we will assume for these analysis that
the number of licenses or at least the
distribution of licenses in in different
groups of faith has been the same since
1982 to now we have checked this a
little bit and it hasn't hardened it
hasn't changed a lot but anyway I let
you know that once we do this we see
that our young pilots the one having
more accidents we wanted to be careless
with everything we
are saying here today I mean the first
thing we said is we are not experts say
say whatever and say okay there you are
so we checked a little bit and we found
in this handbook of aviation human
factors that some people had been
investigating this before with similar
results
it says pilots with the same rate team
who are aged between 24 is that well
okay I'll let you read oh come here
it says that jump pilots experience
between these eight 22 24 experience
three times more accidents than pilots
in this group if you are checking also
the numbers you will see that they are
not the same their reason is obvious we
are not non dimensionalizing with the
same core because we were not able to
know which group they were using in this
book but ok we are reproducing the
result I was telling you that we were
also going to evaluate the influence of
experience in terms of flight hours I
won't go into much detail I will explain
you better here with this widget ok we
can first differentiate well we have a
lot of information here about flight
hours we were really surprised this is a
lot of information I can take for
example the number of hours in multiple
engines that that pilot has in simulator
single-engine make which is going to be
the model that he was piloting when
having the accident rotorcraft
lighter-than-air all gliders lots of
information and not only that I can get
the totals but I can answer gate last 24
hours last 90 days last 30 as a pilot in
command okay so this was really
surprising let's check for example
engine and something like last 30 days
last 30 days okay let's look for a
funnier one first multiple engine lasts
24 hours we can see that there was a
pilot who flew for more than 60 hours in
the last 24 this is strange
that's why I have this layer here so I
can filter a little bit and hopefully I
find 24 hours okay now this is okay
it's working but the first data is here
that's why it wasn't moving so this is
the number of flight hours for the last
during the last 24 hours in multiple
engines here we start seeing that pilots
with less flight experience have more
accidents that violence with more
experience we can also go to the modal
okay
and it's even clearer even more clear
and we could also take instruction
instruction and instruction sorry okay
so formation and experience is important
and how do they promote this I mean
normally you have a co-pilot legs
experience then you have a pilot more
experience they learn from each other
each one has different abilities maybe a
young a younger person can handle the
aircraft quicker
situations but when it comes to take
decisions it's important that someone
experimented okay can can make them so
okay finally is commercial air transport
safer now than thirty years ago we hope
to say yes okay this is these are this
is the graph here we we are seeing the
number of passenger this is the number
of patentees in red we see that there's
a peak here and then it descends but
again we have to non-dimensionalize this
data we need to know that air transport
being growing a lot the last year
this is million of passengers
transported this is million of flights
it's fun of you
okay so it has been growing and now we
can see that half larger airplanes
because there are more passengers and
also that planes are less empty can you
increase the size of the font a little
okay so now here I have the fatality
rate this is dividing the number of
fatalities with with the number of
passengers transported and we were
surprised that everyone is always so in
this part of the graph and they are
telling us that flying is safer now than
before but okay what happens here and we
are curious about that we don't have
much time to perform the investigation
about it but for sure we'll do it
because we found with discovered when we
saw that we were like okay normally we
don't see this but we went to the plots
and so that everyone is so in this part
of course the first the very first thing
we thought is okay you are doing it
wrong don't say others are wrong first
take a little bit but we change against
the the far report and because of the
non-dimensional the non
dimensionalization of the data a non
dimensionalization we are using
different data to non-dimensionalize so
the the number is not the same but we
have the behavior so we think we are
doing it well just to summarize some
quick conclusions
we were telling you that it was
difficult to get the data in Europe it's
not publicly available or at least we
were not able to find it but we are
doing well I think in in data gathering
there's a little bit of
I've been reading their reports and they
are concerned about it I extracted some
quotes and okay it seems that they want
to do it well I hope they are and some
and at some point
release the data available to to
everyone and some other conclusions okay
that analysis is not a bed of roses it's
cool
it rocks but getting the data is hard
thank you and TSV for the data cleaning
it is time-consuming we have to parse a
load we have to play a lot it took it
took a long time but we learnt a lot and
also pandas helped a lot so thank you
very much
argue anymore afraid of flying down
before questions they're really scared I
guess the when I mean Bing Bing have
having seen more time serious maybe than
you the the spike you say that you have
that curve is very intermittent so it's
that much intermittent that maybe
there's not further cause and those
three years so the graph is doing going
up and down all the time so maybe it's a
coincidence you can never tell yeah you
are right about that and with taking
many other reports about safety they
sometimes do ok a trick it's not a trick
but you have to read carefully and they
they perform moving averages and that
kind of things and that's maybe why we
we hadn't seen that before because we
were not paying enough attention today
as more later really one cars are
wiggling a lot the it may you may find
yourself thing I can tell constants
whatever thank you very much for your
presentation okay are you going to make
some correlation with the data that you
carry gathered with security procedures
that are taken in each step of the
flight for example you say that the most
frequent incidents were in takeoff and
landing and I think that's the most well
procedures security in the steps of the
flight so it's like doing the
aggregation of the results in those
inter continuity procedures okay if I
get paid for that I'll do it now okay
it would be it would be really nice and
we've seen that we have
that available a lot of things there are
a lot of things that we can do but we
found sooo discovered and again that
it's really hard dealing with the real
data you have to clean it you have to
get it first
I mean it would be established up well
based methodology to do that any more
questions you have time we still have
time for a couple of questions make a
couple of questions because the coffee
break is not ready yet so no so coffee
break
thanks the speakers